[MUSIC PLAYING]
TINO TERESHKO: Hi, there.
My name is Tino Tereshko,
and I'm a product manager
on Google BigQuery.
And I want to thank everyone
for joining on the session.
There's just so much content,
so many amazing stories
to choose from.
And so from myself, from
all the other speakers
that I'm joined with,
I want to thank you
for picking this
session specifically.
So this session is
all about scale.
Lots of data, large volumes
of data, complex problems.
But it's also
about organizations
that have a rich history
of creative technology
and a history of solving
large-scale problems.
And so what better way to
demonstrate the complexity
and scale of
something than to have
not one, not two,
not three, not four,
but five presenters
for a session?
I think this is a
record for Next.
So all of these organizations
have solved, tackled problems
for their relatively
unique scale.
And if you fast-forward
to 2006, Google
had our own technical
problems to solve.
We couldn't do interactive
analytics at Google scale.
And that's where
Dremel came along.
So Dremel, for the
past 10-plus years,
has been powering Google's data
and analytics infrastructure.
And as most people in
this room already know,
BigQuery is powered by Dremel.
BigQuery is Dremel.
It's the same engineering team.
It's the same infrastructure,
the same codebase.
And so when you think about it,
when you're running BigQuery,
you're running on top
of Google's innovation.
You're running on top of Dremel.
What gives BigQuery its
scale characteristics
is its native
cloud architecture,
cloud-native architecture,
its unique architectural
principles, unique
architectural considerations.
So it starts with a stateless
multi-tenant compute cluster,
which is really what
Dremel is, which
is a really unique offering.
And it's joined together by
a logical storage system that
scales into petabytes and more.
And it's all wired
together by our network
that scales to petabytes.
And then we started
to go beyond that.
We separate compute and
state, intermediate state
during processing,
which accelerates many
of our queries, gives us
performance durability,
scalability characteristics.
And then we allow to
share data in place
without creating data silos,
without moving data around
needlessly.
You bring analytics to data.
You bring users to data,
not the other way around.
And finally, we
wrapped it all around
in a fully managed offering
that minimizes complexity,
manageability, overhead
for your organizations.
Makes it easy for you guys to
use this type of technology
at scale.
So there's this really,
really good quote by somebody
I really respect.
"BigQuery was built for scale."
It's true.
I believe this person.
And so you don't have to believe
me when you listen to this.
Here's a couple of anecdotes
that I found on Twitter
from folks who really, really
appreciate using BigQuery.
"Our queries have gone from
four hours to 13 seconds.
It's awesome."
Here's another one.
"I can vouch for BigQuery.
It's pretty magical."
So now, I want to
discourage folks
from jumping on Twitter
right this second
and professing your
love for BigQuery,
especially using foul language.
Please don't do that, OK?
But the next one is
really my favorite--
perhaps my favorite
Twitter quote of all time.
It's from a gentleman
who works at Spotify.
And two years ago, when we
started to work with Spotify,
this is what he
tweeted, "Finally, I
can tell the world that BigQuery
is the best thing that has ever
happened to me."
I feel like if it's in
caps, I have to shout it.
It's true.
I mean, he probably doesn't
have a lot of interests.
But he is a brilliant
engineer, and Spotify
is a brilliant organization, of
course, a delightful product.
Everyone loves using Spotify.
But also incredibly
creative technologists.
And I'd like to please
welcome one of them
here on stage with me.
Nicole?
Nicole is going to show
the story of how Spotify
has embraced Google Cloud
Platform and BigQuery
specifically for
their use cases.
Please.
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLE BOUCHARD: Thanks, Tino.
I appreciate the intro.
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for having me here today.
I'll start with a
brief introduction.
My name is Nicole,
and I work at Spotify
as a technical product manager
in the data infrastructure
tribe, which is our name
for a department at Spotify.
Specifically, I work with a team
that works on building tools
to support BigQuery
across Spotify.
So we work closely with
BigQuery every day.
We in DI and as a whole
build internal tools
and infrastructure to
support data at Spotify.
So before I get
into this talk, I
want to just
apologize briefly if I
get a little bit technical.
Feel free to find
me after the talk,
and I can explain things
in a little bit more
detail if you have
any questions.
So I thought I'd start with
a very brief history of--
the short history of Spotify
and the cloud, which actually,
now that I think about it, would
be a great name for a band.
I'll have to do that some day.
All right.
So four years ago when
we started the transition
to the cloud--
at that point, Spotify was
almost completely on-premise
and bare-metal.
We were doing--
I think at our largest, point we
had something like 2,500 nodes
in our Hadoop cluster and over
10,000 machines and four data
centers around the world.
And what we were
finding is that even
at that kind of scale,
one of the largest
Hadoop clusters in Europe, it
still really wasn't enough.
We were expanding
rapidly in the US,
and we were really
having trouble
keeping up with the
growth and being
able to do our analytical work.
And that, in particular, was a
really big pain point for us.
Running a single query
on this cluster in hive
could take us hours.
So after a couple of years
of small experiments,
we finally decided to take the
plunge and moved to the cloud.
But before I move on, I
wanted to give a brief plug
to my amazing colleagues,
Josh and Ramon, who
will be giving a talk about
[INAUDIBLE] migration tomorrow
afternoon.
So if you have any interest
in hearing more about how
we did that migration
to the cloud,
please listen in to their talk.
So for us, the move to
BigQuery was actually
a really big success.
It was rapidly adopted by the
Spotify analytics and data
science community.
And to this date, it still
remains one of the most popular
GCP tools we use at Spotify.
For us in particular,
what it really meant
for us was that we were
getting fast results.
We were able to add
capacity a lot easier.
And we found that the
integration with the other GCP
tools was really help.
As well, one of the biggest
wins for us was really
how it democratized
access to data at Spotify.
It was really that ease of use
meant that more people could
be asking more questions and
getting responses faster,
which meant that overall
we are getting a massively
shorter time to insight.
Using SQL particularly as a
querying language was really
powerful for letting
people across the company
ask questions of
our data in a way
that they'd never been
able to do before.
So I thought I'd give you
a quick example of how
using BigQuery
impacted our ability
to ask questions of our data.
So this is a kind of question
somebody, a data scientist,
might want to be asking.
How much time did users in
Spain spend listening to Spotify
in October of 2016?
Before when we were
working with Hive,
it would take us something
like 16 minutes or so
to get an answer for
this one question.
Now when we moved to
BigQuery, the same question
only takes us about 33 seconds.
So as you can see, a huge
sea change in our ability
to get those answers quickly.
Now, if you multiply that by
hundreds of questions asked
by hundreds of people
at Spotify daily,
the kind of impact
this kind of speed
is going to have
is really clear.
And in case you
guys are wondering,
the answer to that
question is the total hours
are equivalent to
nearly 10,000 years.
All right, so what
does it really mean
or what do we mean when
we say petabyte scale?
What does that really look like?
Internally in Spotify we
sometimes refer to this as,
how big is data?
And our answer for that
is really, really big.
So right now Spotify has
about 170 million active users
listening to our catalog of
over 35 million songs in 65
different markets.
So as you can probably imagine,
we generate a lot of data.
And being able to ask the right
questions in the right way
becomes really important to us.
And so that's what we end
up using BigQuery for.
So we use BigQuery to do that
kind of analysis at a scale
that we've never been
able to do before.
Right now we have about 25%
of employees at BigQuery
that are using BigQuery on a
regular basis, either directly
or through custom tooling
on top of BigQuery.
We process around 400 petabytes
of data monthly and store
over 100 petabytes of data,
specifically in BigQuery.
Doesn't even talk
about things we're
storing in other parts
of the GCP product suite.
And that also includes loading
in around 500 terabytes
of new data daily into BigQuery.
And what that means
is that in total we
end up running around 6
million queries a month.
So that's a really big scale.
So for us, that move to
BigQuery has actually
solved a lot of
the issues that we
used to have in our old
clusters, but as we've grown,
we really had to
develop new techniques
to ensure that we're going
to continue to be successful.
For us, we actually
see this as a big win.
We've moved beyond those
lower level problems of,
can we even get the answers
we need, to the higher level
questions of, how do
we continue to ensure
good performance if our
data doubles in size again?
So I thought I'd start
with a few things
here that we've discovered
over the past year that
have helped us scale
effectively in BigQuery.
We found that the
things we're doing
fall into four categories, the
first being administration,
managing how BigQuery is
being used across the company.
Second one is around
education, learning
about how to tune our BigQuery
performance to get the best
results.
Third is integration.
That's leveraging the APIs
and other GCP products
to get the right tool
for the right time.
And then finally, we have
working closely with Google
to improve BigQuery, so working
on our partnership with them.
So I'm going to dig a little
bit deeper into each of those.
First of all, when we talk
about the kinds of things
we are doing in administration
to be successful,
one of the first
things we did was
move to a fixed-capacity model.
This has been
really helpful to us
because it ensures that
we have dedicated slots.
And it helps us be
predictable with our costs.
And that's been
a big win for us.
That does mean we need to
think a little bit ahead
to enable to grow our
capacity, but we've
been finding that it's actually
significantly still better
than the problems we were
having in our on-premise Hadoop
clusters for a growing capacity.
We still have a significantly
faster speed of growth there.
The second thing we do is, we've
been creating sub-reservations,
which are kind of smaller pools
within our larger reservation.
That allows us to isolate jobs
and business-critical projects.
That's actually been
really helpful for us,
particularly
because we regularly
rebalance which projects
have access to which pools.
And that means that
we're getting the best
performance for the right time.
A good example of
this is whenever
we are going to do a large
backfill on our data--
something went wrong or
we need to add some data
into a table that
already exists--
we will move that
particular project
into its own sub-reservation
with an isolated set
of resources that it can use.
And that means it's
preventing that
from impacting the day-to-day
work of everybody else,
but also ensuring that
that particular job has
the resources and needs
to complete on time.
That's been really
powerful for us.
We also make sure that
business-critical projects are
in their own sub-reservation.
That means no matter what
happens they're always
going to have access to the
resources they need to complete
those business-critical tasks.
The next thing we've
been working on
has to do with
education, specifically,
learning how to tune
our performance as being
one of the main things.
For us what that really
means is learning
how do we need to
manage our concurrency?
How do we use batch
versus interactive mode
to help figure out
when jobs should run?
These kinds of
things help us ensure
that we're getting the
best performance when we're
running things on BigQuery.
The second thing we been
learning a lot about
is the impact of
Dremel architecture,
understanding that it's
not a relational database
and that using a
columnar data store
actually provides significant
benefits for certain kinds
of queries but can
be very different
and not work as well for
other kinds of queries.
And so ensuring that people who
are running queries on BigQuery
across the company
really understand
how to optimize for the
kind of architecture
they're running on.
And finally, the thing
we do within Spotify
is we have a very passionate
community of BigQuery users,
and we leverage
that a lot to help
share best practices
around the company.
Next, we work on integration.
Specifically, we use
BigQuery API wrappers
to allow us to build our
own set of custom tools
on top of BigQuery to
meet our own needs.
This really allows us
to do deeper integration
with our own tools
and environment
while still leveraging
that power of BigQuery
behind the scenes.
We find that that's been
really helpful for us
to continue growing and
fine tuning something
for our specific needs.
We also leverage integrations
with other Google Cloud data
products and
specifically the ability
to move data between
different products easily.
That allows us to
really optimize
by using the right
tool for the job.
Finally, we focus on building a
good partnership, specifically
with the Google BigQuery
team, as well with
our strategic cloud engineers
that work with us here
at Spotify.
We work with them really to
help keep expanding the features
and capabilities of
BigQuery that you really
need to be able to operate
at this kind of scale.
What that means for us
on a day-to-day basis
is that we're talking with
them about feature requests.
And as we're pushing the limits
of what BigQuery does right
now, we work closely
in telling them,
hey, these are the
new features we need.
This is where we'd
like to see this grow.
A great example of this
for us is, not too long ago
we were working on becoming
ready for GDPR, the General
Data Protection
Regulation that rolled out
in Europe a few months ago.
And we realized
that the technique
we were using for
encryption and decryption
just wasn't going to
scale to the extent we
needed for DPR compliance.
So we worked closely
with the BigQuery team
to work on new tools
and features that
allow us to do that at the scale
we needed to and at the speed
we needed to do, as well.
That's been really helpful.
And then finally, we've
been working closely
with the support team
at Google to help us
with troubleshooting.
Specifically, whenever we run
into any issues or users have
challenges or we have
performance issues,
we're able to really reach
out and get quick responses
and solve our problems
very smoothly.
And that's it for me.
I'm gonna pass it over to Tino
to talk about the next person.
[APPLAUSE]
Who's next?
TINO TERESHKO: I'm next.
Hold on.
We're good.
Thank you, Nicole.
That was fantastic.
So Spotify has-- you
know, at one point in time
before moving to
Google Cloud Platform,
Spotify had the largest
Hadoop cluster in Europe
or right up there.
And highly tuned, they
spent a lot of time thinking
about performance and
operational complexity.
And now they're working with us
to solve their problems, which
gives them an
opportunity to focus
on delighting their customers
rather than trying to tweak
certain HDFS variables or things
that they may not think are
important for their business.
Well, Spotify has been with
us for three years now.
But I'd like to welcome
onstage our next customer
here, our next speaker,
Tuan, from Oath.
You probably use a property
of Oath every single day
in your life.
And Oath has been with
us on stage the last time
and they've kind of
grown since then.
So it's really
interesting to see
the progression of
where they're going
and where they're
going to be next.
Tuan, please.
[APPLAUSE]
TUAN PHAM: Thanks.
Thank you, Tino.
It's like he said,
my name is Tuan Pham,
and I'm a technical director at
Oath on the Media and Analytics
Warehouse team,
also known as MAW.
And for those of you who are
not familiar or as familiar
with Oath, it was
basically formed last year
after Verizon's acquisition of
Yahoo, which merged us together
with AOL.
And that formed a kind
of house of brands,
represented here by what
we like to show as orbs.
Not an exhaustive
list, but we have
a lot of well-known
properties, products,
including Huffington Post,
Flurry, Tumblr, Tech Crunch,
and Engadget, to name a few.
So when we talk about
media analytics,
Oath, what we're
really talking about
is scale in terms of volume
and velocity of data.
We've spent the
last year working
with all the brands
from the merger,
trying to, from around the world
and across their platforms,
conforming their data
and to bring it together
as it presents a uniform
business view of our company.
We also try to serve a wide
range of users and use cases.
We provide KPI reporting
for executives,
product metrics for product
managers and engineers.
And we also support editors by
providing real-time information
on the performance
of their content.
And so to satisfy
all these use cases
we try to strive to provide
a single self-service,
interactive, and
scalable data platform.
So I'll give a little history
about how we got to this point
and before we had BigQuery.
Generally at companies when
you start with analytics,
you start small.
You have a single pipeline
presenting the data
to analysts.
And then you bring
on more products.
You have more requirements.
And you start to add another
stack, another warehouse.
Companies grow.
You acquire other
businesses that
bring in their own warehouses.
These warehouses then start
to interact with each other
and you have to kind of
reconcile that information.
And so you kind of
land at a picture that
looks kind of like this.
You have a lot of
specialized data stores
that have evolved
into data silos.
You have a lot of
engineering teams
kind of repeating work, which
is not very cost-efficient.
You load data into
multiple places
using different
logic to process it,
sometimes yielding
different results.
And then those
differences eventually
have to be reconciled somehow.
You have [INAUDIBLE] [? text ?]
[? access ?] starts to evolve.
They use technologies
like relational databases
that when you reach
a certain threshold,
can't maintain with the pace
of the services required.
And so overall you have
a very poor foundation
for building an
analytics platform.
So what was the solution?
So Yahoo, obviously being a
huge contributor to Hadoop,
had the expertise to build out
large scale clusters restoring
data, large ETL pipelines.
You know, we have clusters in
tens of thousands of nodes.
So that was not the issue.
And what we really needed
was a complimentary service
that could take that data,
expose it, make it interactive,
scale it with the
needs of the business,
and then also be kind
of cost-efficient.
So for us that
solution was BigQuery.
We used that as the basis
for our new architecture.
It's able to scale
with the needs
as we brought on all the
brands from our merger.
It's flexible enough in
terms of capabilities
to satisfy the
different use cases
that we have for our users.
It's a managed
platform, so it brings
lower operational overheads.
And so it maintains relatively
lower costs for us as well.
So initially when we
started our pipeline,
it was a very basic
Hadoop design.
We ingested our log data and
the bin data into our cluster,
processed that with [? Big, ?]
staged it up in Hive,
and then serviced it to our end
users through our BI analytics
front end tool, which is Looker.
And this served its purpose
when we started off.
And if you remember the
original chain, when you start
small everything works fine.
And as Nicole said, they
started with Hive as well.
But as demands grew,
Hive couldn't keep up
with the services that
we needed to provide.
So in looking at alternatives,
we started to look at BigQuery.
And actually, this
diagram was presented
at last year's conference by
my colleague, Nikhil Mishra.
As our first step for
introducing BigQuery,
we wanted to take a very
measured approach for adopting
it into our platform.
This gave us the opportunity
to work with the dev team,
to understand the
GCP environment,
to understand how that worked
with our Hadoop environment,
let us understand
the capabilities
and the shortcomings
of the tools
and be able to figure out the
right way to integrate it.
We left it in there along
with Hive, and still serving
the data up through Looker,
so that our end users really
didn't experience any
difference in their service,
except maybe some possible
gains in performance
and functionality.
And then it led to our current
design, represented here.
I think the biggest
thing you can notice
is all the data now is being
served up through BigQuery.
We've greatly
increased the capacity
that we store in
there because we
have brought in all this
data and all the brands
from our merger.
We've added in a
real-time pipeline
into our system, which
allows us to take
advantage of BigQuery streaming
ingestion capabilities.
We've also started to take
advantage of additional GCP
services, like
PubSub, data flow,
and data prop because of how
well they work together inside
of that ecosystem.
And really, just overall
presents a simpler design
for the overall architecture
that we're trying to achieve.
And like I said,
that architecture
afforded us the ability
to simplify the design.
We've gotten rid of all
those specialized data
stores and data silos.
We're able to unify things
like the streaming and batch
pipelines so they all
are [? logic ?] [? and ?]
centralized in a
single location.
We have the flexibility
in terms of services
on to provide the data.
We've added our own API
on top of BigQuery API.
So we could provide
programmatic access
to our users that require that.
And as the needs require,
we can scale up both storage
and compute to meet-- to
satisfy the needs as they grow.
And here the numbers kind
of speak for themselves
in terms of the amount
of storage we have,
the number of users, the amount
of users that uses [INAUDIBLE]
in terms of queries
[INAUDIBLE] services.
And really, the numbers kind
of speak to the significance
of our system, kind of the
importance of it providing
value for our company and
the day-to-day decisions
that our colleagues
need to make.
I think the numbers also speak
to the validity of our choice
in using BigQuery as the
backbone of our infrastructure
because it has been able
to grow to match the needs
and demands of our services.
So a couple of
learnings that we've
had along the way, as
mentioned before, GDPR as well.
I'm sure a lot of us had to
face that new regulation that
took effect earlier this
year, which was so enjoyable.
But for us it really presented
a very daunting proposition
of having to restate petabytes
of data within our warehouse
at a fairly frequent rate,
which would have been
very time consuming, very
resource consuming, obviously
very costly.
And so we had to find
alternatives to handle that.
And looking at those
we were able to settle
using BigQuery DML.
And what that
allowed us to do is
to apply massive scale updates
and deletes in our data.
It didn't require us to
do any additional work
in terms of
reprocessing the data
or having to restage our data.
Everything was set.
The functions were
very performant to meet
our expectations.
We did work cooperatively
with the dev team
to get enhancements
along the way,
like being able to apply DML
to streaming tables, which
is one of our requirements.
And we kind of continue
to work with the dev team
to try to improve the
process by looking at things
such as clustering, which
we expect are going to yield
additional performance gains.
In terms of streaming,
obviously being
able to ingest event-level
data into your warehouse
is a huge advantage.
And for us, we kind of
applied a lambda architecture
where we overlay the real-time
data with batch data.
And so if you're querying for
the last 10 minutes or last 10
weeks of data, you're just
going to the same table, using
the same query, essentially.
But it makes you think
in different aspects.
So you have to think in
terms of quotas and inputs
and the amount of events and
the size of those events.
Of course, nothing
comes for free.
So what we experienced with
tables with heavy streaming
ingestion, there was going
to be some performance
impacts in terms of queries.
So we had to work
to either overcome
or be able to work
with those situations.
So in some cases, we used
on [INAUDIBLE] hardware
to offset some of that.
In other cases we're
looking at alternatives,
like micro-batching
ingestion, which
we're hoping will
increase performance
of those situations.
I think the really
biggest discovery for us
is the independence of the
quotas for a lot of the things
that you can configure.
Streaming ingestion quotas
versus batch ingestion quotas
don't impact each other.
Querying as well as ingestion
quotas don't impact each other.
And what it really
gives you is a lot
of flexibility, a lot
of on-demand flexibility
to configure your
situation, especially
in highly dynamic environments.
So you can handle any
event that comes to you
and be able to handle
those accordingly.
So in the media
business we encounter
a lot of high-profile,
high-volume events.
There's late-breaking news.
There's live sporting events.
So we went in an
arrangement with the NFL
to stream their content.
And it was decided
that we wanted
to provide real-time metrics
around the performance
of that streaming.
And for us, that
meant experience peaks
in terms of events
and size of datas
that we don't typically
have to encounter.
So in looking at alternatives
to satisfy those requirements
using the hardware
route, we really
didn't have the runway to
procure, set up the hardware,
not to mention, what do
you do with our hardware
after the event is completed?
And so we looked
to BigQuery being
able to dynamically
increase our quotas,
meet the expectations
of the events,
turn down the quotas
at the end of that.
And the best thing
of all is you only
pay for what you use
during that time.
We were able to handle that
engagement with no issues
in a very short amount of time.
And so overall it was a
very successful engagement.
So what are we looking
to do from here?
Obviously, we want to continue
to unlock the value of data
that we expose in our platform.
We're going to
increase the volume,
looking at additional data
sets that can provide value
for other parts of the company.
Looking at additional GCP
services like machine language,
being able to do things
like user segmentation
and clustering in that platform.
And then we're working
with the BigQuery team
at Google on pre-releases
and alpha and beta versions
of additional features,
which I won't mention here.
Not to take away the thunder
from Tino and company,
but they will be
announcing those, I think,
shortly tomorrow.
And with that, I'm done.
[APPLAUSE]
TINO TERESHKO: Thank you, Tuan.
I will take everything.
TUAN PHAM: OK.
TINO TERESHKO: Thank
you so much, Tuan.
So the impact of the NFL game
event shouldn't be understated.
Tuan and [? Cole ?] came
to us and said, hey, guys
we're going to--
we got this NFL game
going on and we're
going to stream four
gigabytes per second
into your streaming system.
And, you know, we freaked
out a little bit at first,
but they gave us enough lead
time and we delivered it.
The important thing to note
is that all the complexity
was on our side.
All Tuan's team was looking
at is an API surface.
So we went out there
and we made sure
that everything
would work right.
Our SREs were on call.
Everyone was very
happy with the outcome.
And they just sent
[INAUDIBLE] to us.
And then they paid for
only what they consumed.
So it's a great story.
And the [INAUDIBLE],, which says,
as you get to these scales,
the anti-pattern space
expands dramatically.
There are so many things that
are unknowns that you have to--
that you encounter for the
first time that you have to fix.
So folks like Spotify
and folks like Oath,
you know, the problems
that they face and they
work with us to resolve,
straighten our system.
So people who aren't
necessarily at that scale
get a more robust,
more performing system.
Well, now I'm going to kind of
change the gears a little bit.
Spotify and Oath have
been with us for a while.
They're operating
on a huge scale,
but we have a newcomer
into our platform.
I believe in April
Twitter announced
that they chose Google Cloud
Platform as their vendor
of choice or cloud
vendor of choice
to host their next-generation
data analytics platform.
So it's early for them,
but they're already
getting some results.
So I'd like to welcome
a couple of engineers
from Twitter who are going to
be talking about how they're
using BigQuery today.
Please welcome Pawan and Roman.
[APPLAUSE]
ROMAN DOVGOPOL: Thank you, Tino.
PAWAN VALLURI: Hey
there, I'm Pawan.
ROMAN DOVGOPOL: And I'm Roman.
PAWAN VALLURI: We're
from the revenue platform
team at Twitter.
ROMAN DOVGOPOL: And today
we're going to talk about some
of the compelling technical
challenges we faced recently.
PAWAN VALLURI: How BigQuery
helped us solve them.
ROMAN DOVGOPOL: And
where we go next.
So at Twitter we
have a track record
of BigQuery solving some of
the problems that have been
impossible to solve before.
And we really want
to tell a story
of how we started
to use BigQuery
and what drove us to get here.
10 billion advertised
events process daily.
So this is the scale
we have to deal with.
And what happens to the scale
when something goes wrong?
It's really hard to tell.
So we had a need to
write arbitrary queries
against our data sets to
answer some of these questions.
And for a lot of the
data sources we own,
it's either impossible or
extremely time consuming.
So with that in
mind, I want to share
one of the real-life cases.
And I'll pass it to him.
PAWAN VALLURI: So two
quarters ago we had a bug.
Someone reported we showed
ads to the wrong user--
something we should never do.
So first steps, identify if
there are any other campaigns
that were affected.
Fortunately, we have
tools to do that.
It's called business
audit records.
Any change made to a
campaign gets logged
into this table in MySQL.
And so all you have
to do is to query it.
Turns out it's really
hard to do at our scale.
We own one of Twitter's
largest MySQL testers,
and this is one of
its largest tables.
You can literally hear
MySQL scream in pain
when you're trying to query
a 3.2 billion row table.
So how long did it take for us
to finally answer the question?
Were there any other
campaigns that were affected?
It took us two weeks.
It took us two weeks,
four engineers, a DBA,
and a whole lot of pain to
finally answer the question.
How could we do better?
The platform team--
the data platform team
has been experimenting
with BigQuery for a while,
and we thought it was
the perfect technology
to help solve our problem.
With the power of BQ
Blaster that Roman
is going to talk about next, our
data was ingested in no time.
And now things are as
simple as writing SQL,
but without the timeouts.
This takes less than
a minute to execute.
And this was just one use case.
ROMAN DOVGOPOL: So we looked
at this use case and a couple
of other test cases.
And we really saw the
potential to answer questions
in more depth if we move all
our data sources to BigQuery.
And here's where it becomes
a really hard engineering
problem.
How do we generalize
the ingestion regardless
of the source and its scale.
It was never an easy
transition for us.
BigQuery alone was not enough.
And we really had to
build a set of tools
to enable those experiments,
to see what queries we can run,
and also with new questions
we could get answered.
BigQuery blaster or BQ
blaster, how we call for short,
is one of the first tool
that were built for this.
And let's see what it does.
We started with introspection
on [INAUDIBLE] systems.
And with so many data
sources and database types,
we really wanted to build a
tool that would abstract away
the original data source.
So the initiator for this would
be a scouting job that picks up
the data from any original
source that we have
and lands in a
Google Cloud Storage.
The very last step is
a BigQuery import job
that picks up data from
Google Cloud Storage
and lands it straight
to BigQuery table.
So this is the
tool in a nutshell.
We also want to talk
about where we go next.
PAWAN VALLURI: So we took the
learnings from this initiative
and are applying it
to our next challenge.
ROMAN DOVGOPOL: Getting the
data [? organization ?] right.
PAWAN VALLURI: We consume
more than 100 terabyte data
of revenue logs per day.
ROMAN DOVGOPOL: Moving
all of this to BigQuery
is our next challenge, and we
know how to tackle this now.
PAWAN VALLURI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TINO TERESHKO: Thank you, guys.
So you've heard some
of the stories of folks
who are doing interesting
things at scale,
who have lots of data.
But I don't want to
give you the impression
that this is the only thing
that BigQuery is good at.
BigQuery has a wide
range of customers
of all scales and all sizes
and all types of complexities,
so much so that the vast
majority of our customers
are actually using our
perpetual free tier.
You get 10 gigabytes of
storage and one terabyte
of data processed every
single month for free.
So if you have that
much data, you never
have to pay us a penny.
And so we'll encourage you to
try it out if you haven't yet
because it might be a great
tool for your use case,
no matter how big or how small.
And of course, you can go take
a look at cloud.google.com/free
to get your $300 credits that
you can use on BigQuery or any
other product that you may like.
And of course, you
can take a look
at some of the other
sessions that we have.
We have lots of
customers talking
about how they're using
our infrastructure
and our services.
It's a varying
style of use cases.
So you can get a variety of--
you can experience a variety of
what people are talking about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]